entre assurance
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce remake de
notre stop science sur les dragons en
version plus grand plus beau et surtout
plus épique
vous l'aurez peut-être remarqué mais pas
les anthologies et dragons font très bon
ménage
austria draco panty draco hypo draco
palacio draps convicted racault itron
draco ultra kobena tordre à coop et adra
corex draco raptor dracaufeu drac orages
draco mal veille
non non non je m'égare rien qu'en france
vous trouverez le dinosaure tarasco aux
russes qui tient son nom du dragon
provençal la tarasque vous trouverez
vous y brille à un autre dinosaure nommé
sept fois d'après la vouivre un dragon
de l'est ou encore gras ou you dont un
proche parent d archosaures dont le nom
était inspiré du gras oui le dragon
traditionnel de la ville de metz mais ça
ce sont les noms d'espèces aspiré par
des dragons ce qui nous intéresse c'est
ce qui a pu se passer dans l'autre sens
est ce que ce sont les dinosaures qui
ont inspiré les dragons en d'autres
termes nos ancêtres trouvant des os de
dinosaures les ont-ils associés à des
reptiles gigantesque et oui tous ces
dragons ça fait rêver la populace et les
médias alors pourquoi s'en priver et
puis le lien entre dinosaures et dragons
semblent si évident qui peut sembler
absurde de le questionner néanmoins si
un tel lien existe alors il implique
deux choses essentielles
et pourtant pas si évidente que ça d'une
que nos ancêtres ont trouvé des os de
dinosaures bah oui quand on n'est pas
spécialiste c'est pas si simple de
trouver d autres dinosaures encore moins
entier et encore moins de les extraire
de la roche sans est cassé et de deux ça
implique qu'ils les ont reconnus comme
appartenant à ceux de grands reptiles
ce qui voudrait dire qu'ils étaient
vachement balèze en anatomie comparer
alors même que la discipline n'avait pas
été inventée cuvier lui même n'a pas su
reconnaître en iguanodon un dinosaure
quand il lui a été présentée alors la
théorie des dinosaures qui ont inspiré
les dragons elle est certes très
attrayante mais elle part avec deux
sérieux handicap tel un colosse aux
pieds d'argile pour savoir si oui ou non
la découverte de fossiles de dinosaures
a pu inspirer le mythe des dragons il
nous faut remonter le temps loin très
loin dans le temps
quand nos ancêtres découvrez les
premiers fossiles il n'y a pas eu besoin
d'attendre que la paléontologie soit
inventée pour que l'humanité commencent
à s'intéresser et s'interroger sur
l'origine et les propriétés de ces
étranges objets venus des temps
immémoriaux que sont les fossiles
néandertal collecter déjà des fossiles
ils se servaient de certains fossiles
percée des coquillages des dents de
requin ou de beaux morceaux de l'iss de
mer en forme des toiles certainement
pour se confectionner des parures ou
bien simplement pour faire joli comme le
montrent
ceux ci l'ex parfaitement débuté pour
mettre en valeur le fossile d'oursins en
son centre
mais homo sapiens n'était pas en reste
neutre et lointains ancêtres les gaulois
n'ont encore plus lointain que ça les
hommes de cro magnon
déjà il ya trois cent mille ans l'homo
sapiens pas encore sorti d'afrique
collecter ce fossile atteint c'est quoi
cette forme tendancieuses la calme toi
c'est un art auxerre un mollusque à coki
du trias et sa forme tendancieuses comme
tu le dis n'est certainement pas
étrangère au fait que nos ancêtres les
collecter et ramené dans leurs grottes
j'imagine que sa forme phallique en a en
effet inspiré plus d'un pour des rites
liés à la fertilité
oui certainement et c'est ça des rites
des replays la fertilité
les grecs anciens le vénéré certains
fossiles comme en témoignent des
découverte d'ossements fossiles vieux de
plusieurs millions d'années dans des
lieux de fouilles archéologiques vieux
eu de quelques milliers d'années
seulement
entre 1870 et 1880 les fouilles de la
légendaire cité de trois ont révélé des
richesses insoupçonnées dont une
vertèbre énorme daté de 8 millions
d'années mais découverte dans un dépôt
datant lui du xiiie siècle avant notre
ère
le grand historien grec hérodote
rapporte lui même que dans le
péloponnèse d eau géants étaient
exposées dans un temple depuis le 5e
siècle avant jésus-christ c'est aussi à
hérodote qu'on doit la légende selon
laquelle les limites des coquilles des
foraminifères fossiles qui compose de
quelques uns des grandes pyramides
d'égypte seraient en fait des lentilles
une interprétation paléontologique pour
le moins savoureuse j'ai perdu ma
lentille anglaise toujours en 1924 le
paléontologue barnum brown a découvert
une dent d'éléphant fossiles qui était
exposé dans l'école de médecine de cos
c'est louis hippocrate a été formé de
même en 1988 des archéologues allemands
fouillent en un temple dédié à la déesse
héra sur l'île de samos découvrir un
fémur de rhinocéros fossiles
probablement un rhinocéros laineux tout
près de l'hôtel de cérémonie à quelques
kilomètres de là dans l'acropole denis
coria était découvert il ya deux mille
ans un autre fémur de rhinocéros laineux
ses curiosités paléontologique étaient
déposés là suppose-t-on comme des
reliques témoignant des temps anciens où
les titans et autres géants ravagé le
monde
l'île de samos est aujourd'hui
parfaitement connu des paléontologues
comme l'une des plus grandes sources des
plus beaux gisements de fossiles de la
fin du cénozoïque l'un de ces gisements
étaient connus des anciens grecs sous le
nom de la paix leymah le champ de
bataille où il pensait que dionysos et
son armée d'éléphants avait livré
bataille aux amazones et que leur sang
avait faire rougir la plaine
la couleur rouge
la terre vient en fait de l'oxydation du
fer en climat tropical climat qui était
favorable à pléthore d'animaux exotiques
qui ont ici laissé tant de fossiles que
bien souvent il n'est besoin que de se
baisser pour les ramasser
quand ils ne pointent pas directement le
bout de leur nez en dehors du sol dans
le lot il y avait d'ailleurs bel et bien
quelques proches parents des éléphants
les mastodontes donc ma foi
l'interprétation mythologique n'est pas
complètement fausse
un tel culte des fossiles s'il a bien
existé ne serait pas si éloigné de la
vénération que portaient les gens du
moyen âge à certains fossiles de
mammouth notamment qui était exposé dans
les églises en tant que saintes reliques
comme l'a abondamment documenté culié
dans ses recherches les ossements
fossiles les médiévaux penser que ces
fossiles étaient les restes pétrifiés de
licorne ou deux géants bibliques ou
historiques tels goliath ou t'es où théo
baucus ouais enfin confond une bande
mammouth avec celle d'un humain faut
quand même n'avoir jamais regardé dans
la bouche de son voisin la dentisterie
n'était probablement pas une priorité à
l'époque ni l'anatomie comparée
il semble à moins que ces temples et
églises n'est servi de sorte de cabinet
de curiosités oui d'ailleurs le premier
empereur romain jules césar
non non pas césar entre ça et les
gaulois falloir arrêter d'apprendre
l'histoire dans les bd un bon l'empereur
auguste donc posséder dans sa villa de
l'île de capri sa propre collection de
fossiles
une sorte de cabinet de curiosités avant
l'heure beaucoup de ces fossiles
provenaient des nombreux chantiers de
construction que l'empereur avait initié
à rome ainsi que des contrées qu'il
avait un pacifié et figurer notamment
une défense du mythique sangliers de
calédonie ramené du temple grec de tj où
elle était vénéré d'après sa taille
immense et sa courbure cette défense
serait plus probablement celle d'un
mammouth que d'un sanglier
les fossiles sont aussi depuis longtemps
utilisées dans la médecine
traditionnelle
lambres qu'on confondait volontiers avec
de l'uriné de lynx les bébés les mythes
les dents de requin ou glossop être ou
bien encore les épines d'ossun
fossilisés était impliqué dans diverses
préparations censé vous prémunir d'à peu
près tous les maux de ce monde en
commençant par les troubles
gynécologiques la gangrène la dépression
ou bien encore écrasé mélangé avec du
vin elle vous apportera à n'en point
douter la sécurité du foyer c'est
vachement spécifique quand même
l'utilisation en médecine traditionnelle
si elle n'a pas passé le cap des siècles
des lumières en occident encore que je
connais un ou deux bouquins
lithothérapie qui voudront bien de
prescrire un peu de bois silicifiées
contre la distraction et la perte de
mémoire
c'est sûr qu'un bon morceau de bois
silicifiées si vous visez
bien dans le portable ça empêche la
procrastination et les autres y sont
même utilisés en homéopathie une
pratique 100% moderne et occidentale bon
correction bien qu'elle soit devenue
très minoritaire en occident après le
siècle des lumières parce que
l'homéopathie --et que c'est pas si
répandue que ça non plus l'utilisation
de faux cils en médecine traditionnelle
reste toujours très pratique et en
extrême orient en chine par exemple les
fossiles sont appelés dans ou aux deux
dragons et sont broyés et consommer avec
le thé c'est ainsi qu'un beau jour de
1935 sur un marché les contreforts de
l'himalaya un paléontologue s'est rendu
compte que l'une de ses tantes d'aragon
appartenait en fait est une espèce
nouvelle de primate géant
le gigantesque itec ce dernier est
devenu ensuite très célèbres comme
faisant partie de la courte liste
d'espèces ayant pu inspirer le mythe du
yéti l'homme de pékin connu une histoire
similaire car il provient d'une colline
connu sous le nom de montagne des eaux
de dragon rendez vous compte une espèce
d'hominidé aussi rare et il a failli
partir hantise n
ouais bon mais on va pas jeter la pierre
aux chinois tout le monde même en
occident et les indiens d'amérique font
ça et c'est quand même d'un savant
chinois qu'est venue la toute première
analyse paléontologique digne de ce nom
dans ses essais du bassin des songes le
grand chêne quo le léonard de vinci
chinois rapporte en effet la découverte
en 1088 de bambou fossiles dans une
province où le bambou ne pousse
normalement pas il en déduisit avec brio
que la région devait être autrefois
marécageuse dans un temps reculés c'est
probablement pas pour rien
qu'aujourd'hui presque une nouvelle
espèce de dinosaure sur deux est un
nouveau fossile chinois c'est que
chercher des fossiles là bas c'est une
tradition millénaire
littéralement bref ces charmantes
intérêt pour les fossiles qu'ils soient
scientifiques et ses tics ésotérique ou
pour faire du béton et ça ne date pas
d'hier
et à défaut d'être toujours rationnels
la pensée humaine exècre les mystères et
leur préfère de bonnes vieilles
explication aussi farfelue soit elle
alors comment diable ne pas fantasmer
sur l'existence passée l'inspirent ibles
dragon rongeurs d'homme quand on tient
devant soi un os titanesque des
dinosaures comment résister à la
tentation de cette explication
merveilleusement simple et séduisante
dinosaures égale dragons qui osera dire
que ces reptiles géants du mésozoïque
n'ont pas inspiré les non moins
reptilien drago j'ai dit reptilien et au
reptilien le dinosaure mais mais mais
ils sont pas du tout reptilien ces
dinosaures comment voulez vous que les
gens assimilent ces trucs en plumes et à
des dragons ben c'est qu'elle est bien
mignonne et d'une
et et infantile et attendrissante jolie
petite théorie mais je crois qu'il ne
tient pas la route
comment ça elle tient pas la route mais
c'est ce que la plupart des gens pensent
tout bas ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont
raison
en fait je crois qu'ils ont tout compris
à l'envers parce qu'ils confondent
causes et conséquences que quoi que
commença à l'envers eh ben il est tout
aussi vraisemblable que les gens
d'aujourd'hui sachant l'existence des
dinosaures et croyant à tort qu'ils
ressemblaient à des reptiles se sont
convaincus à rebours que les anciennes
légendes des dragons était basé là
dessus
non parce qu'il faut bien l'admettre des
légendes l'impliquant défaut s'il y en a
peut-être quelques unes mais des
légendes qui font directement le lien
entre dinosaures et dragons la
littérature est formel il y en a pas des
masses
on peut même dire qu'elle insère des
godzilla est c'est court pas les rues
prenons le dragon de klagenfurt une
ville d'autriche le folklore local
rapporte que la ville aurait été fondée
en 1250 au moyen-âge après qu'un
terrible dragon était été rasées là sous
les assauts de preux chevalier une
statue monumentale et grandeur nature a
même été érigé sur la place du village
en 1590 pour commémorer ce haut fait et
voici qu'en 1335 un carrier découvre le
crâne d'une bête énorme qu'on attribue a
immédiatement aux dragons pendant cinq
siècles cette pièce magnifique a été
fièrement exposée dans le hall de
l'hôtel de ville comme témoignage des
triomphes d'éclat gagnent fourtoy sur la
terrible dette
il faudra attendre 1840 pour qu'enfin un
paléontologue de passage identifie
formellement la bête
il s'agit d'un crâne d'un dinosaure et
nonda rhinocéros laineux datant de la
dernière ère glaciaire toujours en
autriche un mix night une grotte inspiré
l'effroi cas elle était remplie
d'ossements on la disait habité par un
dragon
mais une fois étudier les rays se sont
avérées appartenir à un dinosaure
another n'ont toujours pas voudrais tu
viens arrêté c'est bien c'est pénible là
mais madame donc non pas un dinosaure
mais un ours des cavernes et à toutes
s'accordent de mammifères datant une
fois de plus de la dernière glaciation
le paléontologue autrichien au teigneux
abel en 1914 rapporte ainsi plusieurs
autres histoires similaires en autriche
et en suisse
en 1672 dans la mystérieuse grotte de la
licorne dans les carpates à mende le
crâne d'un authentique dragon a été
découvert et qui s'est avérée n'être
toujours pas un dinosaure n'ont toujours
pas un ours des cavernes
encore une fois mais ya que des ours
dans tes histoires non non non
des requins et pas n'importe lequel le
megalodon bien longtemps dans la
péninsule du yucatan des dents de mégalo
dons ont été collectés par les aztèques
comme des offrandes votive
ah oui du coup dans de faux cils serpent
à plumes aztèques et pouf ça fait un
dragon non non pas du tout il était tout
à fait conscient que c'était des dents
de requin ce qui est remarquable en soi
l'identification d'une espèce éteinte
avant même que le concept d'espèces état
ne soit inventé et ça vaut le respect
mais n'ont toujours aucun rapport avec
des dinosaures ou des dragons et en
france à aix en provence je sais que sur
le rocher du dragon il y avait autrefois
un dépôt d'ossements et paix qu'on
pensait avoir été fait par
l'accumulation des cadavres laissés par
un dragon affamés c'est bien une preuve
ça hein et non en fait ce dépôt daté du
cénozoïque il n'y a donc aucune chance
qui défie parent dinosaures non aviens
bon accord chercher du côté des dragons
en espérant y trouver du dinosaure c'est
pas la bonne solution
tapas des légendes basé sur des fossiles
de dinosaures plus tôt et l'a peut-être
que parmi elles on trouvera du dragon
dedans ah ah si si si si j'en ai les
empreintes de dinosaures de saint
laurent treize près de
barre-des-cévennes serait celle de
gargantua mon temps à paris c'est
toujours pas un dragon ça donc on passe
à la suivante
des squelettes fossiles cité dans ce qui
est devenu aujourd'hui le dinosaur
provincial park au canada était vénérée
par les indiens comme représentant le
grand père des buffles et des buffles
non jeu c'est pas mal mais suivant bon
au portugal alors près de la chapelle
notre dame du cap i spit celle des
traces de dinosaures sauropodes ont été
prises pour celle de la mine géante de
la non moins géante sainte vierge quoi
mais c'est une blague c'est des mules
géante de métier c'est tout ce que tu as
à si j'en ai une gouleyante des
peintures pariétales réalisé par des
indiens navajos ressemble trait pour
trait à des empreintes de dinosaures
carnivores
on s'est même qu'il y avait un lieu
couvert d'empreintes attribués aux
dinosaures qu'il désigne comme étant
l'endroit des pics d'oiseaux géant piste
d'oiseaux géant mais c'est pas mal ça
mieux encore à l'autre bout du monde les
aborigènes d'australie ont eu un
attribut de semblables et empreintes de
dinosaures à leurs hommes et me
légendaire enfin au lesotho une grottes
décorées par les bushmen situé non loin
d'un site à empreintes de pas de
dinosaures porte une peinture en forme
de pied de dinosaures similaire à celle
faite par les indiens navajo
l'originalité de ce site ce sont les
petits personnages dessinés juste au
dessus et qui ressemble à des oiseaux
regardez on voit même leur petit
croupion tu chrome une ue
il ressemble aussi à des oiseaux parce
que qu'ils sont pas de brun s'est pas de
dragon
ouais mais c'est cool quand même alors
tous ces peuples ont été les premiers à
reconnaître que ses empreintes
appartenait à des animaux qui
ressemblaient à des oiseaux c'est bien
ça wahou mais quand tu penses qu'à
l'époque les anglais ils croyaient que
les dinosaures ils ressemblaient à des
gros lézard balourd qui traînait lors
que au sol comme au crystal palace
non mais il était carrément retard en
fait les scientifiques anglais mais
c'est qui le scientifique à deux balles
qui a fessé dino dégueulasse et qui
s'attaque non pitié dis moi que c'est
owen de jurassic vente
j'espère qu'il nous a pas entendus sur
un terrible son courroux vengeur va
s'abattre sur ne nous fera plier notre
insolence dieu ait pitié de nos âmes
c'est ça ricciardo owen
[Musique]
ne fait aucun geste si ça se trouve sa
vision est basé sur le mouvement chacun
pour soi c'est pas moi c'est lui aa
bon bah avec tout ça on n'a toujours pas
de dragon avec nos dinosaures non j'ai
ici un rapport datant de 1941 dévoilant
la possibilité que des empreintes du
trias et inspiré la légende du dragon
fafnir a enfin le succès et la gloire
huawei en plein rapport de 1941 on est
loin de l'époque médiévale d'une et de
deux les empreintes c'est pas des eaux
et de trois essais plus important ce ne
sont pas les empreintes de dinosaures
mais deux quiero terium donc pas de lien
entre dragons et dinosaures et non
toujours pas l'historienne à brienne
mayer le paléontologue et big toe et
bien d'autres ont fouillé le sujet de
fond en comble il n'y a rien ils
admettent la possibilité d'un lien assez
équivoque entre le proto ceratops et la
légende du griffon mais pas avec les
dragons tous les grosses dents et les
eaux on a des êtres humains géant 5 0
des mules géante pour les grosses
empreintes du cyclone géant évidemment
pour les crânes d'éléphant bref du
n'importe quoi chez ans en europe et en
orient au sein oui il y en a mais point
de dragon ya peut-être qu'en chine mais
là bas il appelle absolument tous leurs
fossiles des eaux ou des dents de
dragons et pas seulement les dinosaures
par conséquent il semble bien que ce
n'est que très récemment qu'on a
commencé à vouloir voir un lien entre
dinosaures et dragons d'ailleurs vous
aviez remarqué que les dragons
asiatiques ont des bois de cerfs à la
place des cornes comme s'il avait été
inspiré par un cervidé fossiles et
contrairement aurait-il la salamandre lé
pavillon aux oreilles comme un mammifère
donc si vous êtes du genre à vouloir
continuer de croire dur comme fer que
les dragons sont des dinosaures mal
interprétés sachez qu'il y a tout autant
d'arguments pour soutenir l'hypothèse
que les dragons sont en fait des
mammifères tenez vous le pour dit c'est
vrai qu'en même temps c'est pas facile
de trouver un os de dinosaures même
quand on en cherche et oui ils sont trop
rares trop profondément intérêt est trop
fragile pour que quelqu'un qui ne sait
pas exactement ce qu'il fait puisse
prendre toutes les précautions
nécessaires à son extraction al'inverse
les mammifères géants de la fin du
quaternaire comme les ours des cavernes
les mammouths et les rhinocéros laineux
n'ont que quelques milliers d'années
leur zoo sont assis très souvent restées
intactes et on les trouve en grandes
quantités dans des strates de surface
sur le bord des rivières ou dans des
grottes parfois même sans creuser ou
s'en aller chercher les historiens des
sciences ont montré que la plupart des
légendes impliquant des fossiles sont en
fait basé sur des fossiles de mammifères
âge de glace principalement parce qu'ils
sont plus faciles à trouver par accident
est mieux préservé léger au mythe de
monstres c'est à dire les histoires
inspirées par des phénomènes géologiques
peuvent avoir de multiples origines
une curiosité géologique intrigante à un
lac une grotte un paysage hors du commun
ou même encore l'existence d'un joyau
précieux par exemple la légende selon
laquelle les dragons porterait une gemme
dans leurs crânes viendrait des crânes
fossilisés de mammifères du gisement d
si ouali qu au pakistan située sur la
route de la soie ces collines regorge de
mammifères fossiles dont des ancêtres
des girafes dans la boîte crânienne
c'est bien souvent remplis de cristaux
durant la fossilisation comme une géode
mais aussi comme du crâne et l'aspect de
geod sont autant d'éléments frappant
l'imagination qui aurait pu inspirer
contes et légendes aux marchands de
passage en europe certaines légendes de
dragons sont en fait née après qu'une
dépouille de crocodile ramené par
quelques pèlerins marchands ou croisés
est été pendu comme curiosité dans une
église
rien à voir avec des fossiles donc
l'assimilation du crocodile à un dragon
se faisant malgré le fait que l'on
connaisse pertinemment l'origine
véritable de la relique et c'est par
exemple le cas des dragons de paris
marseille ou encore de l'hôtel dieu de
lyon et qui sait si le crocodile offert
par l'empereur auguste et la ville de
nîmes et qui lui sert toujours l'emblème
n'a pas un jour donner des idées de
tarascon quelques compteurs camarguais
mais le plus important c'est de remettre
ces histoires dans leur perspective
historique
ce qu'il convient de rappeler c'est que
les dragons les serpents et les reptiles
de manière générale ont toujours servi
de symbole du mal dans la mythologie
judéo chrétienne quand ils ne sont pas
carrément à l'incarnation de satan
lui-même dès les premières pages de la
bible l'agente reptilienne est utilisé
comme une allégorie du diable le serpent
infâme tentateur incitant au péché
originel pour l'imagerie populaire
chrétienne le dragon plus ou moins
serpentiforme est complètement
interchangeables avec le diable comme en
témoigne l'archange saint-michel célèbre
pourfendeur de la bête saint georges le
tueur de dragons ou sainte marthe qui
dompta la tarasque c'est toujours le
même refrain des copier coller une sorte
de propagande si vous préférez des
histoires racontées par les évangélistes
pour mettre en images la puissance de
leur croyance en pays non converti un
sens où une sainte
un dragon malfaisant le saint combat le
dragon avec des prières et les signes de
croix puis le tient en laisse avec sa
ceinture avant de le pourfendre
généralement le précipitant dans un trou
le tout accommodé à la sauce les us et
coutumes et légendes locales
c'est toujours un saint qui terrasse le
dragon sinon c'est un noble
dans ce cas c'est la noblesse locale qui
tire notoriété et profite du prestige du
récit clergé et noblesse vous sentez ce
petit goût de moyen-âge qui pointe le
bout de son nez là quand on veut
comprendre l'origine du mythe des
dragons il ne faut donc pas oublier que
pour les premiers chrétiens d'occident
le dragon est l incarnation du mal
absolu
j'ai nommé le paganisme la bête immonde
et la légende du dragon vaincu si tout
simplement une métaphore pour parler de
la christianisation bref le dragon c'est
une métaphore du mal et s'ils crachent
du feu c'est parce que sa bouche n'est
rien de moins que l'antre des enfers
elle même où ça semble logique
finalement les mythes de dragons peuvent
tout aussi bien n'avoir rien à voir avec
les fossiles ou même avec un quelconque
événement qu'ils aient pu exister les
feuilles s'ils peuvent être à l'origine
de vieilles croyances locales mais le
tout a été passé à la moulinette durant
si longtemps qu'il est le plus souvent
impossible de le prouver
et enfin et surtout on sait déjà d'où
vient le mythe des dragons le chercheur
français julien dupuy a montré que les
dragons sont en fait il y ait à l'opa à
la terre - fossiles les dragons serait
en fait apparu dans l'imaginaire
collectif au paléolithique en afrique et
aurait suivi la dispersion des hommes à
travers le monde
des dragons était alors interprété comme
une force de la nature une sorte
d'explication à divers phénomènes
géologiques et météorologiques
étrange et fascinant comme les orages
les cascades les sources et surtout les
arcs-en-ciel énormément de culture
décrypte encore aujourd'hui les arcs en
ciel comme des serpents géants
surnaturel crashers d'éclairs ce serait
le dragon des origines et si vous pensez
qu'on ne peut pas inventer des histoires
pareilles de toutes pièces demandées
vous combien de temps cela prendra avant
que le bouche à oreille ne transforme en
dragon les déjà mythique alligator des
égouts de paris
le monstre du loch ness sous ses traits
reptiliens n'est-il pas lui-même une
légende de dragon contemporaine en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il n'existe
qu'un seul mythe liant les dinosaures
aux dragons et ce mythe c'est que les
premiers auraient inspiré les seconds et
oui en fait les dinosaures ont inspiré
les dragons c'est ça le mythe
merci à tous
[Musique]